[Music]
this is seattle's way of writing a
musical wrong it's a tribute concert put
on to remember an almost rock star whose
voice was silenced years ago but whose
music is as alive as ever
[Music]
her voice was super powerful she could
sing on top of a super loud guitar-based
rock band which is not an easy feat
she was the only beautiful black goddess
who could rock with such a pure heart
that she did and that's why she should
be remembered
[Music]
you probably haven't heard of the late
tina bell she was the fierce front woman
of a band you probably also haven't
heard of bam bam back in the early 80s
[Music]
they were making music around the same
time as grunge pioneers like alice in
chains the melvins even the early days
of nirvana
and yet in almost every telling of that
vibrant seattle scene
tina bell and bam bam
get barely a whisper
how rare was it for a woman of color to
be fronting a punk band then
tina was probably the only one in this
city the only one yeah terry morgan is a
music promoter who used to book bam bam
back in the day back when what became
the seattle sound
was just beginning to brew
did she influence grunge was she one of
the foundational artists for grunge is
that going too far you know i would say
yes they did influence the grunt scene
because
they did it before anybody else i love
the music
you won't get an argument from matt
cameron one of bambam's first drummers
bam bam i thought always fit in really
really well with that kind of early
formation of what became you know the
seattle rock
revolution if anyone should know that
it's cameron who went on to become a
grammy award-winning drummer with sound
garden and pearl jam the tina factor was
was huge does it make you angry yes are
you kidding me
bam bam's bassist scottie ledgerwood
says the lack of recognition hurt
everyone in the bank
but especially bell
you think it sort of ate a weight at her
it literally did they were afraid that
america wasn't ready for a black girl to
front a hard band you know she's
supposed to be a hip hop or a diva queen
she can't be up there you know so fierce
and beautiful like that but she was
this is how i remember
the person she became on stage that's
tinabell's son tj martin who followed
his mom into the public eye winning an
oscar as a documentary filmmaker it's
kind of incredible to think that a black
woman leading a punk band
is still an anomaly
at this day and age he remembers his mom
as a woman who never really talked about
sexism or racism
except in her songs
[Music]
tina bell eventually walked away from
her band and her music
she died unexpectedly in 2012
and by then
she'd been forgotten by almost everyone
she retracted from the world became kind
of a recluse
very much stuck to herself now there is
people taking a second look right it's
people taking a second look but
history's already kind of been written
right and history gets written by the
victors this is the soundtrack to my
life and yet just this past summer fans
lined up at the central saloon the same
seattle bar tinabell used to play all
those years ago oh yeah i was a disciple
om jahari first saw tina bell as a
teenager
she went on to lead bands herself in
part because of the fierce impression
that tina bell had left behind
her performance on stage was just that
much more powerful because she
definitely commanded a room of
predominantly white spectators
filling in for belle at that tribute
concert she says
felt like it validated bam bam's place
in history
so what do you say to critics though who
say yeah they were a good band they
maybe even liked them but they don't
think that they were necessarily
foundational for grunge i would say
balderdash
poppycock
do i think she had a hand informing that
sound absolutely
she may not have gotten a record deal
back in the 80s but she's got one now an
album of bam bam's remastered music is
expected to drop later this fall social
media is all a buzz about it
even if it's decades too late
here's this woman
who kind of broke down some barriers
whether she was conscious of it or not
that has now had a ripple effect in
inspiring people
in 2021
that's the power of music in the end to
be able to reach back through the past
and in the process
find where it speaks to the present as
well
[Music]
for cbs mornings i'm lee county in
seattle
[Applause]
i was introduced to grunge in the 90s
i'm a seattle guy yeah so imagine this
this young black kid from the city going
and looking for a flannel shirt with cut
off sleeves because i heard the grunge
music for the first time you didn't
stand out or anything did you a little
bit you got the guns for the cut off
flannel though i don't know if i could
pull that off uh tita bell's a badass uh
no doubt good on good on lee cowan for
bringing her story back to national
attention because clearly it's deserved
no doubt some of the bands that we love
and appreciate i bet you they looked up
to her during that movement and i i like
the new phrase balderdash and poppycock
i like that that can come in handy
shout out to tina bell in the good music